it's summertime that means snow cones
box-office hits and embarrassing camp
crushes but 50 years ago in the United
States it also meant voting rights it
was called Freedom Summer and it was a
critical moment for the civil rights
movement young activists both black and
white from the north and south went to
Mississippi to help register black
voters at the time even though blacks
made up half the state's population only
6% were registered to vote not by choice
remember we're talking about the South
under Jim Crow a system of so-called
separate but equal laws that segregated
blacks and whites it was also a time
when white supremacists went around
wearing bedsheets intimidating and
brutalizing blacks when it came to
voting blacks faced all kinds of threats
physical and economic things like if you
vote you're gonna lose your job then you
have things like poll taxes and literacy
tests which made it even harder to vote
despite being violently attacked Freedom
Summer was effective a year later
President Lyndon Johnson passed the
Voting Rights Act it banned these tests
and taxes and also made sure that states
in the Jim Crow South couldn't change
their voting laws without getting it
approved by the federal government so
why now 50 years later is it still so
hard to vote in the US well that's kind
of by design the election of Barack
Obama in 2008 saw historic number of
young low-income black and Latino voter
turnout that didn't sit well with
Obama's political opponents since 2010
22 states many of them republican-led
have been tightening their voting laws
making it more difficult for these
communities to vote for some of these
states it was a direct challenge to the
Voting Rights Act so how are they doing
it by passing voter ID laws if you don't
have government-issued photo
identification you can't vote though it
might seem reasonable according to the
ACLU 21 million Americans don't have
photo ID more often than not they're
low-income elderly and people of color
some states are going a step further and
requiring voters to show proof of
citizenship in Arizona and Kansas tens
of thousands of eligible voters haven't
been able to register to vote in recent
elections because of these citizenship
laws then in 35 states if you've been
convicted of a serious crime sometimes
even a
one you lose your voting rights right
now there are nearly six million former
prisoners who can't vote states have
also straight-up purged voters from
lists without telling them it's usually
by accident when someone's name is
similar to that of say a former felon
but millions of eligible voters have
been wrongfully taken off list and
turned away it pulls finally things like
restricting voter registration drives
moving polling stations to few voting
machines limiting the number of hours
polls are open and getting rid of early
voting have all made it tougher to cast
ballots but last June voting rights took
its biggest hit yet the Supreme Court
gutted the Voting Rights Act ruling that
regulating voting laws in former Jim
Crow States is unconstitutional within
hours of the decision states scramble to
tighten their laws North Carolina passed
some of the most restrictive ones in the
country even cutting a program
encouraging young people to vote state
legislators claim that these new
requirements prevent voter fraud
nevertheless some of these laws are
being challenged in courts and in the
streets but most of them are sticking
admit term elections in November half of
Americans will find it harder to vote so
what do you think does the US need
another Freedom Summer